what's your name I ma'am hi my name is
Deshawn so I kind of started between New
York and then he said my first interest
business way back in 1998 I'm gonna pick
up two aspects of all you talked about
first thing you said was when marketers
get to something they kill it yes
don't eat it so second you talked about
the Facebook back pages yes
I recently book tickets and hotel room
in England post my booking my facebook
newsfeed was certainly filled with
offers of hotels in London that's right
it pissed me off correct don't you think
Facebook is now over marketing itself to
the last point we had that is becoming
an invasion of privacy where I actually
raised my hand and said don't call me
send me a text if you want me to call
call you back not yet why do you say
that
because I look at the sales the numbers
the only reason your theory as I setup
is 100 percent correct that they will
come if Facebook stops innovating
Facebook impresses the [ __ ] out of me
they're the only company that has
continued to innovate when they started
going into not showing every pages stuff
everybody complained what I realized
they were doing was they're trying to
protect the thing they care about which
is they don't want to piss you off you
decided to be pissed off by that and
that's great and I don't disagree and as
everybody gets good at this and
everybody does it that will happen the
reason I tell you that I don't agree
right now is because I'm looking at the
numbers we have growth in conversion not
decline decline will come decline will
come in 15 or 16 and 17 and then I'll
look at it and I'll be like AHA decline
and then I'll start worrying about some
other [ __ ] so but what I do know is that
SCM is down 17% and click-throughs this
month that Google AdWords which I would
have sat here in 2003 and yelled a bat
and I would have said would have been
ruined and you would have asked me you
know I don't click them as much anymore
because I used to like when Google was
clean and I would say you're right
and I'd say but not yet and you'd say
why do you say that and I would say
because I see the numbers and then that
decline started happening in 2012
because we got behavior eyes right and
so that's my answer my friend
Marketing in the year that we live in
too many people project what's gonna
happen too many people don't want to
agree with what's happening I don't give
a [ __ ] I just care about right now